and as promised the uh the combo that is
taking over showtime
with their uh late night talk show jesus
and marrow on showtime
sundays and thursdays at 11 p.m and now
the authors of god level
knowledge darts life lesson from life
lessons from the bronx
there they are right here jesus nice and
the kid marrow how are you guys
you're hey what's up rich how are you
guys how's it going man we're good
chilling in the presence of a legend no
right back let's have bomb out
[Laughter]
kind enough to say it before i hit
record with the f-bomb in there so
[Laughter]
i'll take it either way you want to work
blue or not but this is uh
apparently a family out here we're out
here doing a press tour promoting a book
doing like
27 uh interviews today but this is gonna
be our best one so
okay i appreciate you you know uh
bringing your a game to the rich eisen
show here thanks very much first things
first
thank you did you wear that shirt for me
or have you been wearing that throughout
your entire day
this right here yes i wearing this
staten island pizza rat shirts
just for you because it would have been
lost on any other show if we
you know like you you want the host to
see the shirt and appreciate it and i
know you're a fan
well you know what i'm i'm born in
brooklyn but raised in staten island i
moved there when i was
six months old and so i guess this is
this has been something on my show um
that has been brought up quite
a bit by the guys on it just to try and
troll me i think
that they say that staten island is not
really
a borough of new york city whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey hey hey hey hey hey whoa
wait oh
all you got to say is meet me on victory
boulevard it will
fall where he's going pal
all right there you go put some respect
on the ferry put some spec
on the verrazano bridge okay that's
right it is a burrow
it is a girl how dare how dare you
disrespect shaolin
like come on come on like even before
before i had my guy chris who's from new
england
um i made it made sure because he's
constantly giving me crap for it i made
sure
he mentioned it when we had method man
in studio i'm like
oh you must say and uh it did not go
it didn't i'm sure it wouldn't i'm sorry
because everyone i know from staten
island
has a chip on their shoulder because
they've been people trying to erase them
from new york history
forever all right even though if there's
a fair chance because this
gets a little nautical with using a boat
to get around that part the rest of us
new yorkers are like what's going on
but other than that you guys are a
borough okay
all you need is all you need is a bridge
from like the new york side i'm in
jersey now so like
i'm you yeah you're a borough you're
good we got we got one from brooklyn
and the other from new jersey we got
that and even though we take a lot of
everybody's figurative crap
but literally took everybody's garbage
for 30 years literally
give it up for fresh kills landfill all
right a new york institution
frightening
said to stop dumping on the bronx all
our garbage went to fresh kills
put some respect on that legend fresh
kills was the original madison square
garden
yes i agree especially since the current
one is the resident of the dumpster fire
of the new york
talk about let's speak on it let's speak
on it or we could talk about that right
now but
i love that fresh kills by the way the
fact that you said fresh kills landfill
like it was one of those chants from the
bleachers in yankee stadium
is the next level fantastic that if you
ever been to the
you know the old yankee stadium there's
a good chance at some point in time they
did chant fresh kills landfills
it is possible that it is possible in
the early 80s or the early 70s that
that yes uh a landfill was starting at
like third base for the yankees
yes it was a relief it was it was the
relief picture that they drove out to
the mound in the little
pinstripe model yes and the pinstripe
and the pinstripe sedan
yes just just just tearing up the field
because the relief pitcher is too too
important to walk out there
i love it let's bring that back it's
that steinbrenner swag bro
it permeates the franchise you know what
i'm saying
let's put pinstripes on like a chrysler
yeah and make sure that the fat ass
coming in the sixth inning
who gives up five runs can't doesn't
have to run
he's not tuckered out by the time
exactly it's not there
you know we're gonna we're gonna update
it and they're gonna come out in a tesla
truck
it's gonna be great it's fantastic elon
musk
kids today do not know about the bullpen
card that is right they don't know
yeah no they don't know anything about
it could you imagine it
they would the carbon footprint of it
like just it's just so egregious
it's not electric
it's so wasteful this is great man jesus
and marrow here on the rich eisen show
this is
fantastic all right so let's get into uh
let's get into the mix
because i see if i'm not mistaken oh i
gotta put on my glasses here
it looks like um mirror that you are
wearing a knick-knack yeah
but it's you know it's it's all black
it's just one more
it is all better and more we're in
mourning paying proper respect for our
hopes and dreams of a championship
ruining it again so it's only right you
know what i mean all black
this is perfect bring it up with you
guys i didn't i haven't i didn't talk
about it on the show yet this week
but the fact i don't know if this is
in fact a sign of the times or the fact
that we're still not going to get out of
any of the
the awful times that the knicks are in
the fact that charles oakley
got bounced off of dancing with the
stars in front of carol baskin from the
tiger king this week wow
wow dude like you can't win it
it is but as a knick fan as a knick fan
we're used to early exits
let's keep it funky right yeah like come
on
we're just happy we were just happy to
make the playoffs he's gonna be honest
you know
you know what i mean like he did his
thing you know he danced a little salsa
you know
what his interpretation of salsa
his interpretation is also really looked
like he was going for offensive rebounds
so maybe that's the reason
it did look like it was trying to take
the charge like you're not supposed to
set your feet
and dance yeah like you're dancing with
her don't set a pick against her
like i'm like it's dancing you can lift
your pivot foot
it's a dancing competition it's okay
it's like you're not gonna get a
traveling call i just saw that i'm like
and you can't win you can't win oh my
god
all right give me some hope do you have
any hope or you're just we're not gonna
because you're trying to stop
listen i'm going to give you some i'm
not going to give you hope i'm going to
give you
uh the knicks uh flavor hope which is
false hope
and i'm going to tell you that joel
embiid and
possibly fred van vliet will be the
point guard and the center on the next
next year but that's probably not gonna
happen because it's the knicks
but that's nick's hope that's the best
nick's hope because you as a nick fan
you have nowhere to go but up
so you know what you don't you have to
throw out logic you have to throw out
sense reason
people having to want to play where they
want to play like last year
you could not tell me and mirror we were
not getting not just kd
but also zion and also who's the third
person
kyrie yeah yeah and we're watching espn
there's like there's absolutely no
chance that trade's gonna happen and
we're like
nope not hearing it let me get ready to
buy my kd knicks jersey
and we've done this so many times and if
we did it for lebron
right if that was gonna happen giannis
would absolutely come and we all know
that that's never gonna happen right now
it's never gonna happen
but then listen what about but you even
brought it up
jesus you even brought it up now if this
is about
loving basketball and appreciating good
basketball
on behalf of new york city durant and
kyrie
are in brooklyn would either of you
consider that
would either of you oh rich coach
becoming a net fan
rich you're an espn og you know that is
not allowed
no i know i'm from new york but you
can't do that
but it's not just because they used to
play on long island and from new jersey
but they're in brooklyn now and that's
durant that's kyrie
i mean that's i'll watch okay and you
know i'll be happy for them
i will nev but i i will never recognize
them as new york's basketball team and
most new yorkers won't maybe that would
change with the next generation if the
knicks
continue to just be a dumpster fire on
33rd street
but you know what it is we grew up with
the knicks and being and
being a team fan means you're there for
the bad days and sadly we've had more
bad days and good days but then i look
at
cubs fans and i look at pirates fans and
you have to see what they've been
through
and eventually every dog has his day and
one day the knicks are going to be great
and when that day happens i don't think
the world is going to be ready for it
because people are going to die at that
parade
and i'm one of them okay i mean you can
talk about cubs fans but they didn't
tell bill murray he had to go in just in
the same entrance as the rest of the
fans you know what i mean
they didn't take like andre dawson and
drag his ass out of madison square
garden let him rot in jail overnight you
know what i mean like that's
you know when you look at it like that
what i need you to do is zoom the camera
out
just zoom the camera out don't look at
the don't look at the
the real issues there like no okay no no
that's the skirt garden everyone wants
to play here
where's me playing here you know they're
back on basketball
plays here like that that's not gonna
focus on it
no highlights in hd okay what other
what other arena has a sabaro's right
across the street huh
huh all right i should zoom the camera
out
we're going to go me going down the
dolan wormhole i
i just like that man so intensely that
it's just a gravitational pull i can't
get it it is
but you can't do anything about it you
can't do anything about it
like it's like it's like if you're a new
yorker you're obligated to hate james
dolan and the mayor no matter who the
mayor is
and what i do
you know what i knew the james dolan
situation was completely out of control
when the fan told him to sell the team
and he tried to fight the fan outside
master square garden
at that point there's no redemption
there's no going i'm a drunk he called
that guy
but at least i respect you guys so many
celebrities from new york won't even
talk about it because they don't want to
you know mess with their opportunity to
go to the games or anything like that
yeah i feel like we blew that a long
time ago
yeah we've got to come out of pocket for
those yeah that's the thing
if you pay for the ticket yourself it's
different okay because if you pay for
the ticket there's not you're not even
on their radar that you're there
and then they have to know you are and
then if you want to throw me out even
after i've paid for my own ticket
that's gonna probably not end well for
the organization you know what i'm
saying that
because that is a thing like do you
really want p two people who are seen as
the face of
the team like we're always repping the
next we're always talking about the
knicks if we get banned
just phil rizzuto and the yankees all
over again you know what i'm saying
listen
to it it's to the point where like
bleacher report literally mocked up an
illustration of
when when barry got drafted they mocked
up an illustration of us
flanking r.j barry out of bodega that's
how synonymous we've become with the
knicks so it's like
you know we got to tell you you know you
got to tell the truth that's why that's
why if you go to the nets
you would have a lot of influence you
know what i'm saying
yeah no even worse i've been to a nets
game and they treated me so well
and free food free drinks and it was
like anytime you want to come you walk
up but then they put me on the jumbotron
and then people was like wow traitor i
wasn't a traitor didn't have any nuts
gear on
but you know what as a knick fan i'm not
known i'm not used to happiness it felt
weird
it felt i was free food and drinks the
team is winning people were happy
this is not how i'm used to watching
basketball you ever taken a rescue dog
and then like you go to pet him and they
like you know they're like whoa
yeah hey i don't know what's going on
here yes that's kind of us
you know what i mean with the knicks
it's like you know if i go to a net game
and i get that and
i fee i have similar experiences jesus
had yeah i'd be like whoa whoa
oh the shrimp cocktails for me
i felt so i don't know back to somebody
else
i felt so lost in the third quarter
because i keep looking at the scoreboard
and i was like when are you guys going
to lose 30 by when you guys gonna blow
30 points and lose this lead
i don't get what's going on the fourth
quarter is coming on you're just going
to keep a lead
this is you guys what is this are you
guys playing defense
you guys aren't putting six power
forwards on the floor at the same time
what's wrong with you
at the end of the game the announcers
were like the nets win i had to use
google translate on my phone
figure out what that would admit like
what is what is win
what is win you know what but shout out
to the knicks because the only thing
that's giving me hope with the knicks
though
is i'm in jersey now gambling is legal
and the knicks those spreads are
outrageous
like the next it's like the next the
nexus
you know uh underdogs by 26 and a half
points i'm like oh that's a lock
and then they lose by 30 have five and a
half it was by four you know
and then i'm screwed but that's the
mantra in this house
even to my kids my my oldest son is nine
years old and
he knows if the next cover they won
in our hearts in our hearts also in all
seriousness being a knick fan it's about
the
it's about the journey not the
destination okay yes all right well
and that's why i'm saying maybe your
journey should go through brooklyn look
um
your your book this has been phenomenal
you guys have to keep
we have to we we have to do like a
regular zoom uh yeah
let's do about your book before because
i know you guys have uh other
other places to go right now god level
knowledge darts
life lessons life lessons from the
moment it's just a just life
advice from our living in the bronx
stories experiences
mural talks about relationships i talk
about the heartbreak of
2004 watching the yankees lose to the
red sox
talk about the very vividly uh speaking
of the next
i talk about lj's four-point play in
there you know what i mean which is like
literally like that was what the whole
garden just went crazy that's yeah
oh man i talk about i talk about kobe's
61 point game i was there for that and
then i was there when mello broke it
with a 62-point game even though kemba
walker wasn't playing you know it was a
tuesday night but we'll still take it
listen lots of good experiences you'll
read it you'll feel like you're in the
bronx
and you'll be like wow those two guys
i'm glad they're no longer those people
they've grown up i should follow their
exams yes
to choose your own adventure book well
congrats on all your success man your
show was just renewed for a third season
you had your book and i
i mean again and then your bodega boys
podcast available wherever
all the podcasts are if there's any time
you know i could return the favor to you
and anything that you got going on i'd
i'd love to do that you know you can you
can return the favor
right now okay okay uh
should i uh should i trade
uh uh uh
it's a fantasy football question yes yes
it is you're going through your phone
right now okay yeah yeah all right
can i do it for you marijuana okay i've
been i have a proposed trade
all right okay it's been proposed to you
or you're proposing
it it's been proposed to me okay okay
and it is for me to give up
uh oh oh
miles sanders okay eagles you know give
up miles
give up miles and get amari cooper in
return and a random wide receiver who
i've never heard of
so two wide receive do you know the name
of the random wide receiver that you've
never heard of
uh man do not okay i don't no
uh i would i would stick tight with
miles sanders you tell them to
pound sand unless you need receivers do
you need wide receivers in the world i
don't i
don't i mean i got one guy hurt mike
evans is doing is is doing
okay you know okay yeah i would say so
yeah what's the name of your fantasy
team
uh barlow's zantana
arlo's santana like after kevin barlow
the
the running back or or is that no after
uh carlos
what another akas from uh the bodega
boys oh
yeah it's a play on xanax x bars
okay very good okay
any other advice or whatever i'm
available for you for you guys congrats
again everyone should get
uh your book where all books are sold
life lessons from the box
god level knowledge starts life lessons
from the bronx and of course your show
on
sundays and thursdays 11 p.m eastern on
showtime and bodega boys podcast
available wherever
thanks for coming on guys it's been a
blast thanks for having us
let's do it again let's do it for like
two hours next time let's definitely do
it again
that'll be a pleasure shout out to shout
out to wu tang that's it
it's staten island hey you got a problem
with shaolin meet me i victory boulevard
i'll take my shirt off we'll fight
there you go you're like i'm back in
high school
don't talk about my banana sauce like
that
jesus and mero right here on the rich
eisen show